Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Era il 2009,
ero in viaggio
e per la prima volta vidi
una rappresentazione del mondo
simile a questa cartina geografica.
Il mondo veniva presentato
attraverso un punto di vista
diverso dal mio:
come vedete, l'Europa non era nel centro.
E personalmente mi sentii un po' persa;
e questa sensazione
di disorientamento iniziale
fu seguita dalla curiosità.
Volevo capire se la gente del posto
vedeva il mondo attraverso
la stessa inquadratura.
E così, durante il viaggio
chiesi ad alcuni locali,
alcune persone del posto,
di descrivere il mondo
attraverso un disegno;
e questi sono alcuni dei disegni
che collezionai  durante il viaggio.
E come vedete, l'Asia è nel centro.
Non solo: se focalizzate l'attenzione,
magari potete anche indovinare
dove mi trovassi.
Guardate bene: ero in Giappone.
Come vedete, è il punto focale
di tutti questi disegni.
E non solo: è nel centro, è il più grande,
ma è anche il paese più definito:
guardate il dettaglio.
E questo esercizio mi incuriosì così tanto
che negli anni a seguire
ho continuato a raccogliere
mappe del mondo disegnate a memoria.
E attraverso conversazioni
interessantissime, e vari viaggi,
ne ho collezionate a centinaia.
Non è assolutamente
un catalogo scientifico;
ma mi permette di osservare
che tutti quanti raccontiamo il mondo
attraverso la nostra esperienza.
Il creatore si mette nel centro,
e in base a ciò che decide di includere
nella mappa, o omettere,
ci racconta che cosa
è importante per lui o per lei.
Questo è un hobby.
Ma è più di una raccolta di mappe:
è una raccolta di storie.
E queste storie, oggi, mi permettono
di introdurre il mio argomento:
come possiamo andare oltre
alla nostra storia, alla nostra mappa?
Come vedete da questi disegni,
ognuno di noi ha una percezione
del mondo individuale.
In altre parole, non vediamo
la realtà così com'è,
ma la vediamo attraverso
il filtro dell'esperienza.
I dati sono uno degli strumenti
che abbiamo, però,
per andare oltre
questa percezione soggettiva.
Sebbene anche i dati siano soggettivi,
e abbiano dei bias,
perché ovviamente sono creati da persone,
sono uno strumento
incredibilmente accurato
della realtà che ci circonda,
e quindi lo possiamo usare
per avvicinarci alla complessità
e per navigarla.
Ma i dati, a livello grezzo,
sono incomprensibili,
hanno bisogno di una voce.
Ed è questo che faccio
nella mia professione:
dare voce ai dati, perché i dati
non parlano da soli.
Il mio lavoro è il data design,
e consiste nel creare esperienze
che ci portino alle storie, dietro i dati.
E questo linguaggio prende varie forme,
si plasma sulle storie
che voglio raccontare
ma anche su chi voglio raggiungere.
Mi vedo come un ponte
tra la sorgente e il pubblico.
E a volte, come vedete da questa raccolta,
queste forme sono statiche;
altre volte interattive;
e altre volte addirittura sperimentali,
le abbiamo portate in opere teatrali.
L'obiettivo è che i numeri
non rimangano numeri,
ma che le storie arrivino.
Perché, vedete, c'è questa tendenza
di pensare ai dati
come a un materiale asettico,
come a numeri e basta.
Qualcosa che non ci rappresenta,
per gli esperti.
Ma per me, i dati sono
un materiale veramente creativo,
che mi permette di esplorare il mondo,
di saziare la mia curiosità
e poi di esprimere le mie scoperte.
Come definizione, un dato è
"una descrizione elementare della realtà".
E queste descrizioni le possiamo trovare
in qualunque cosa facciamo,
in qualunque esperienza.
Anche, ad esempio, guardare un film.
Questa è la ricostruzione
del famoso film di Kubrick,
"The Shining".
Analizzando la struttura,
e alcuni elementi visivi,
ho scoperto attraverso i dati
che, ad esempio, il colore
è strumentale nella narrazione.
Guardate, ad esempio, queste due scene:
hanno tanti elementi in comune
a livello stilistico,
ma ce n'è uno che prevale:
il colore, appunto.
Soprattutto quando ci rendiamo conto
che queste due scene
sono state girate in due bagni:
verde acceso e rosso brillante
sono alquanto inconsuete,
come scelte cromatiche;
e quando riportiamo queste scene
all'interno di tutta la sceneggiatura,
a livello cromatico
effettivamente sono atipiche.
Vedete, Kubrick non aveva
lasciato niente al caso,
e anche il colore diventa
uno strumento narrativo
per dirci che "Hey, c'è qualcosa
che sta succedendo qua:
Jack, il protagonista,
sta perdendo la testa,
sta iniziando a comunicare
con il soprannaturale."
Questo è il potere dei dati
di farci tornare all'esperienza iniziale
con più consapevolezza,
con più conoscenza;
e apprezzare la realtà
che c'è attorno a noi,
per andare oltre alla nostra percezione.
Però, oggi, non voglio raccontare
di come raccogliamo i dati,
ma piuttosto di come li comunichiamo;
e quindi, vorrei portarvi
un po' nel mio lavoro.
E voglio usare due progetti
a me molto cari,
per raccontarvi
di come traduciamo i numeri
in esperienze di storytelling.
Il primo progetto è tratto dal mio libro,
"The infografic history of the World".
Abbiamo creato 100 infografiche
che narrano l'evoluzione del mondo
e l'evoluzione dell'uomo,
e ogni infografica parte
con una domanda investigativa.
In questo caso, per questo esempio,
la domanda di partenza
è alquanto complessa:
qual è stato l'impatto
della guerra nel mondo?
È impossibile rispondere
in maniera conclusiva, ovviamente,
a questa domanda;
ma nei dati possiamo trovare uno spunto
per descrivere
la complessità della realtà.
E la fonte scelta, in questo caso,
ci offre una lista di conflitti,
la durata, dove sono avvenuti;
e soprattutto il sacrificio umano,
quante persone sono morte
in ogni conflitto.
Poi, decidiamo che lessico usare.
Ovviamente non scriviamo con parole,
ma scriviamo con immagini.
E questo lessico è visivo,
e in questo caso sfrutto
quello che è il pattern recognition,
ovvero come il nostro cervello
riesce a identificare
dimensione, proporzione,
distribuzione delle forme astratte,
e la semiotica, ovvero il significato
dei segni e delle immagini.
In questo contesto, uso il papavero
come simbolo di commemorazione ai caduti.
Alcuni di voi, magari,
staranno pensando alla referenza
al papavero della canzone di De Andrè,
"La guerra di Piero".
Beh, nel paese in cui vivo, l'Inghilterra,
il papavero è un simbolo nazionale
di commemorazione ai caduti.
Simboleggia la speranza
per la vita, e la pace;
ma al tempo stesso,
con il suo colore rosso
il Red Poppy, ovvero il papavero rosso,
ci riporta al campo di battaglia,
a vedere il sangue versato sui campi.
E questo è il risultato:
un paesaggio commemorativo,
in cui i dati hanno una voce visiva.
La linea del tempo inizia nel 1900.
Ogni conflitto
è rappresentato da un fiore:
è ancorato a terra
nel momento in cui la guerra inizia;
l'altezza rappresenta la durata,
e sboccia per indicare
il sacrificio umano.
Come vedete,
nella prima metà del Novecento
ci sono due guerre
che hanno causato milioni di morti,
la Prima e la Seconda Guerra Mondiale.
Ma è nella seconda parte del secolo
che le guerre si sovrappongono,
e diventano più lunghe.
Ce n'è una che, addirittura,
copre sette decenni: Israele e Palestina.
E soprattutto, quest'idea
che la seconda parte
del Novecento sia così caotica
ci porta oltre alla nostra storia.
Ebbene, nella forma interattiva
di questa infografica
possiamo anche mettere
a confronto due storie:
l'Occidente, il nostro mondo
e il resto del mondo.
Ed è qui che il data design
ci può portare oltre alla nostra storia,
ad ampliare la nostra visione del mondo.
Quello che spero di fare,
con il data design, dando voce ai dati,
è creare empatia.
Per andare oltre a quella
che è la statistica,
ma per ricordarci
che dietro questo paesaggio,
dietro questa mappa,
ci sono delle vite,
per raggiungere le menti
e arrivare al cuore.
Questa per me è
la grande sfida del mio lavoro:
ricordarci che dietro ai grafici,
dietro alle statistiche, ci sono persone.
E di questi tempi che, ovviamente,
di dati ne abbiamo sentiti a bizzeffe,
e i grafici sono strumentali per capire
la complessità del nostro mondo -
e in questi tempi di pandemia
sono diventati una bussola -
mi sono veramente posta questa domanda:
come possiamo andare
oltre a queste rappresentazioni
per ricordarci che dietro ogni grafico
ci sono delle persone,
ci sono delle storie umane?
E all'inizio di quest'anno,
collaborando con il Museo di Londra,
abbiamo cercato di dare
una risposta a questa domanda,
nuovamente molto complessa
e che nuovamente non può avere
una risposta conclusiva:
qual è stato l'impatto del virus
nelle nostre città,
e in particolare nella mia città, Londra?
E questa è la mia risposta:
un video, un film,
"London under the microscope"
che cerca di ripercorrere un anno
che nessuno di noi mai si dimenticherà,
il primo anno della pandemia.
È impossibile raccontare le storie
di nove milioni di londinesi;
ma ciò che ho voluto fare
è creare un contesto condiviso,
che potesse poi essere navigato
in maniera soggettiva.
E questa mappa è stata ricreata
mettendo assieme la geografia di Londra
e quella che è l'immagine
visiva del virus,
sfruttando un po' la biologia
della struttura del virus.
E per non appiattire la realtà
reinventando la mappa,
ho deciso di codificare
vari livelli di complessità.
Quindi abbiamo: la mobilità
del trasporto pubblico, sulla membrana;
abbiamo i casi, le morti;
e abbiamo anche i vaccini.
E poi, un contesto editoriale
che ci ricorda gli eventi.
E a questi dati abbiamo dato
una voce visuale ma anche una voce sonora,
per creare veramente
un contesto più viscerale
che ci riporti a quello che è stato
il primo anno della pandemia.
Non vi posso far sentire tutto il film,
ma vi vorrei far percepire un estratto:
i 30 giorni che precedono e seguono
l'annuncio del terzo lockdown a Londra.
(Video)
Come vedete, qua abbiamo
i quartieri di Londra.
Ogni quartiere ha un picco,
che rappresenta i casi;
e queste particelle,
che emergono ogni giorno, sono i morti.
Mentre si dissolvono,
vanno ad accumularsi nel background,
che cambia la scena completamente,
la trasforma in bianco e nero.
E qua siamo entrati nel terzo lockdown,
all'inizio dell'anno.
CoVid ha significato
qualcosa di diverso per ognuno di noi,
e quindi l'emozione che viene generata
guardando questo film
sarà soggettiva, individuale.
Ma quello che spero il progetto faccia
è ricordarci che oltre alla nostra storia
c'erano tante altre storie.
Quindi quello che volevo fare
non era quello di creare
una risposta conclusiva,
ma piuttosto di portare
un contesto condiviso
e creare uno spazio di riflessione.
Con questi due progetti,
spero di avervi potuto raccontare
quello che è il mio obiettivo
nel mio lavoro, nella mia ricerca:
quella di farci sentire
chi c'è dietro ai dati.
Per vedere oltre al numero,
per farci sentire le implicazioni;
e per ricordarci, appunto,
che se conosciamo i dati,
se conosciamo queste storie,
ci possiamo sentire più connessi
alla realtà che ci circonda.
E penso che il design
possa veramente apportare
un bagaglio di riflessioni
ed emozioni ai numeri.
Ma per veramente
risvegliare i nostri sensi
a quella che può essere definita
una anestesia nei confronti dei numeri,
penso che il mio lavoro non basti.
Il mio lavoro ha bisogno di tutti voi:
collettivamente, bisogna guardare il mondo
con occhi più curiosi,
continuare a chiederci i perché delle cose
e magari cercare nei dati delle risposte;
ma anche pensare
in maniera critica a questi dati.
Invece di estrapolare una statistica
per confermare il nostro punto di vista,
ricordarci che, anche se non siamo
direttamente rappresentati,
ci possono essere altre storie;
e quindi, guardare al mondo
con cuori più compassionevoli.
Perché vedete, prima di diventare
un numero in una tabella,
o un puntino su una mappa,
siamo delle persone.
Visto che oggi di informazioni
ne avete sentite tante,
di dati ne abbiamo sentiti tanti,
proviamo con un'esperienza
a risvegliare i nostri sensi.
Proviamo a vedere se riusciamo
a creare una mappa assieme.
Ho bisogno della vostra partecipazione,
ed è il momento di usare il cordino.
Creeremo una mappa tutti assieme:
sarete voi i designer.
Ok.
Voglio prendere in prestito
i vostri occhi curiosi,
le vostre menti critiche,
i vostri cuori compassionevoli;
e cercheremo di dar forma all'amore
con questo cordino.
Prendetelo da un capo,
e pensate a cosa significa
l'amore, nelle vostre vite:
può essere una persona, o più persone;
può essere un gesto, o un momento
che magari vi ha cambiato la vita.
E vorrei che ve lo legaste al dito:
scegliete voi la mano.
E il modo in cui lo legherete al dito,
o magari il numero di volte, l'intensità,
quanto stretto lo stringete,
o se volete farci un nodo, o un fiocco,
rappresenterà la vostra storia.
Siate creativi: non c'è
forma giusta o sbagliata.
E poi, vorrei che portasse
l'altra mano all'altro capo.
E adesso, vorrei che alzaste
tutti quanti le mani
e avvicinaste le mani quanto più possibile
alla persone che vi stanno
sedute a fianco,
così che saremo un network.
Siete bellissimi, è bellissimo vedervi.
Ok: abbiamo appena dato forma
ad una storia invisibile.
Certamente non possiamo leggere
le storie individuali di ognuno di noi;
ma ne possiamo percepire l'intensità,
perché ci abbiamo appena messo il cuore.
Ed è proprio questo
il mio invito, nuovamente:
a non perdere di vista le storie umane
che ci sono dietro un cordino,
una mappa o un grafico,
perché solo così i dati
si possono connettere.
Perché come abbiamo visto oggi,
abbiamo la scienza e la tecnologia,
abbiamo il design e le arti visive
a dare forma ai dati.
Ma è solo quando queste forme, queste voci
incontrano la nostra umanità,
e noi ci sentiamo parte
della stessa mappa,
che allora i dati
non rimangono mera informazione,
ma diventano conoscenza.
E la conoscenza genera azione.
Grazie.
(Applausi)